welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and spider-man no way home was
embedded with even more secret layers of
meaning than we realized because this
film's official screenplay was just
released and let me tell you while it
wasn't staring wide-eyed and screaming
and crying at this movie in imax it was
one hell of a read that still made me do
all of those things i poured through all
181 pages of this to find a ton of new
details that are not that obvious from
watching this film some deeper context
subtext literal texts that made me
appreciate this movie's attention to
detail even more and the fact that this
movie snuck in a stan lee cameo i swear
to god if they weaken it stan lead this
let's break this down now the version of
the no way home screenplay that has been
released is the final script the draft
submitted for awards consideration film
scripts are really living documents that
evolve throughout production and
post-production to give each department
a blueprint or the movie as it comes
together so this draft is likely one
that the screenwriters assembled after
the film's release to best reflect what
we actually saw in the film the title
page reads serenity now the no way home
production title before its public title
was decided and announced serenity now
is a reference to the sitcom seinfeld
season 9 episode 3 in which george's
father frankestanza repeats the phrase
serenity now really is a calming mantra
that he heard from a self-help tape but
because this is frankistanza it just
makes him angrier and bottles up his
rage
now when we first heard the production
title of this movie was going to be
serenity now it just seemed like a
random seinfeld joke really many
production titles are just random
phrases however if you think about it
the core emotional arc for peter parker
in no way home is to embrace aunt may's
zen mindset of helping people instead of
dooming them and despite peter's rage
exploding against green goblin he must
channel his inner serenity now and let
it go now the opening pages transcribe
exactly what we saw and noticed in the
film until page 5 the exposition says
that flash's phone screen shows the
daily bugle official tick tock now you
may have caught this in the quick cut
two in the movie but it is fun to see
the script tie in with that whole thing
of that betty brandt being the daily
bugle tick tock intern now another fun
visual detail that's hard to catch while
watching the movie when the brick flies
into the window caught by charlie cox
matt murdock daredevil the script
confirms that the newspaper message
wrapped around the brick misspells the
word of believe almost like they didn't
want to spell this pro-mysterio message
with the word lie in it now jumping
ahead to the bridge battle against doc
ock described on page 50 the direction
reads spider-man versus doc ock mono
amano amano ah etc because you know like
16 different appendages are fighting
here and then a bit further down it
directs doc ox tentacles to grab
spider-man's arms in a vice as another
tentacle latches onto the daily bugle
helicopter the fact that dock uses the
helicopter rotors to try to kill peter
is obvious enough but i only now put it
together that dog was using the daily
bugle helicopter one of peter's other
enemies the daily bugle to try to kill
him in this moment when the daily beagle
by reporting all this horrible stuff
about peter has been trying to kill him
up until this point everything about the
daily vehicle is deadly to peter then
jumping ahead to page 76 when peter
finds may having tea with norman osborne
the description reads no armor dressed
in ill-fitting clothes from the donation
bin nursing tea in a mug he looks tired
disoriented even fragile so when we
watch the movie it isn't confirmed where
exactly norman got these green and
purple sweats but now we know it was
from the donation bin which means that
norman walked into this feast center
still wearing his goblin armor so
someone at feast maybe even may saw him
enter the doors as a multiversal super
villain and still decided to give this
guy a second chance then shortly after
this on page 80 another subtext detail
that i appreciated when norman meets mj
in the sanctum at first he thinks mj is
for mary jane as we know from the film
she corrects him but then the script
says norman reacts understanding another
universe which leads him to say
fascinating so i love this just from mj
standing for different names in this
reality the brilliant norman osborne
already deduces the multiverse logic of
that and how the magic keeps some
aspects of the identity the same but
warps them slightly really the bigger
detail is a few pages after this doctor
strange's box now hearing the name of it
i thought it was the machina dico thomas
but in the script it is spelled la
makina di cadaves which is italian for
the machine of cadavers italian being a
key language because it's a nationality
of cagliostro the sorcerer who wrote
commerce's book of caglio stroke but the
word cadavers is an important easter egg
because it refers to the crystal of
cadavers which comes from the marvel
team up number 21 in 1974 in which
spider-man teams up with doctor strange
to fight a sorcerer named zandu who
hypnotizes peter into stealing the
crystal of cadavers which zandu needs in
a plot to resurrect his wife the word
cadavers a play on cadaver and what's
amazing about this is months ago i
actually found a clue in the trailer of
a car on the bridge with a license tag
of mtu 2174 which was a reference to
this exact comic issue but that plate
was removed from the final cut of the
film now on the next page page 84 it
says that when strange activates a box
golden light was supposed to begin
enveloping the villains in their cells
but interestingly they left this out of
the film and saved it for when the spell
was complete at the end now in peter's
confrontation with strange in the mirror
dimension on page 88 peter using
geometry to best strange is described in
a pretty fun way strange looks around
webs everywhere closing in on him as the
rocks turn and spin not so random after
all as strange is completely ensnared in
a web i love describing it this way
because it reflects the way strange used
to see the universe as random tiny
momentary specs within an indifferent
universe but the lesson strange must
learn is that there is always a deeper
order to the chaos than he thinks yeah i
know i can seem kind of wound up as i'm
going through these theories and easter
eggs so to relax i like having a nice
glass of wine after a hard day i
especially like having a glass that
someone else has done the work of
picking out just for me well bright
cellars matches your preferences to the
perfect wines from around the world you
take their simple seven question quiz
and then they ship you a customized box
of wine right to your door each box
comes with these cool wine educator
cards that teach you all about the wine
here's the box i got this month what do
we got in it
this month's box includes the cabin five
according to the card this zinfandel is
like a rich strawberry jam with ripe
fruit flavors contrasting beautifully
with the notes of freshly cracked black
pepper velvety texture with silky
tannins i think i'm just gonna walk
around the apartment with this bottle
like a pirate pirate with great taste
i've received a bunch of boxes from
bright sellers over the past year and
based on my feedback they've adjusted
the wines that they send me every time i
get something new i always enjoy them
their selection includes wines beyond
your typical grocery store wine with
sustainable varieties and biodynamic
wines bright cellars is giving our
viewers 50 off their first six bottle
box that's six bottles for just 45
crazy good value support the channel by
following the link to take the quiz and
get started today so jumping ahead to
aunt may's tragic death on page 116. i
totally did not catch this under the
music and the tears of this moment but
among peter's last words to me are it's
just me and you okay it's just me and
you calling back may connecting with him
in homecoming peter you have to tell me
what's going on just lay it out it's
just me and you which in that moment i
always interpret it as her way of saying
it's just down to the two of us since
ben died we have to trust each other and
now peter is echoing that here that she
will always be that important mother
figure to him now one of my most
favorite things about reading the script
is also my favorite part of the film the
introduction of andrew garfield peter
and toby mcguire peter and in the script
started on page 119 to avoid confusion
among the peters these two are labeled
as web verse peter and raimi vs peter
from their forward crediting the
directors mark webb and sam raimi for
their contributions to this franchise
and then a few pages later on page 127
when mj and ned bring the other peters
to the midtown roof they're initially
silhouetted in the light of the moon and
peter doesn't recognize them at first so
the script says peter takes a protective
stance guarding his friends meaning that
peter did not know what other
multiversal villains could have arrived
threatening his loved ones so his
instinct is to protect his only loved
ones left from getting killed until he
realizes that these two are on his side
and this is pretty clear in the scene i
just love reading this in the script on
page 129 as all three peters finish each
other's with great power lines the
exposition says they're overwhelmed by
this uncanny connection bound together
across universes by those words just
further underlining that quote as a kind
of absolute point that defines all peter
parker's regardless of their dimensions
fun little detail on page 133 when mj
calls to peter and all three peters
confusedly point at each other the
script straight up says memes showing
that they deliberately wanted this to be
a recreation of the spider-man pointing
at each other meme and then during the
final battle when andrew garfield peter
chats with max stillen about the
existence of a black spider-man on page
159 it says webb vs peter nods there
probably is now the way they formatted
this is interesting because it's
described as andrew garfield peter's
thought but also it's still formatted in
a way to leave open for interpretation
that miles morales spider-man does
indeed exist in this live action
multiverse then onto the final moments
in this donut shop one of the weirdest
things i found in the script on page 177
peter finds mj talking and laughing with
an older customer a stan lee look-alike
now when i saw this movie i did wonder
why the camera lingered on this guy in
mj's moment with him i wondered if he
could be some vip or comics writer but
he is an actor named edward force and
now the script is suggesting that this
guy was cast for his resemblance to stan
lee did the script intend for us to see
this resemblance are we meant to see him
as a stanley variant or really is it
just to evoke the memory of stan's mini
cameos the kind of vague deja vu and
facial blindness is that him no not
quite that mj is now feeling in this
scene either way i think it's just a
cool weird thing to keep in the script
and this scene hints at mj's inner
thoughts while chatting with peter when
he finishes her line about expecting
disappointment because then you'll never
actually be disappointed it says a
flicker of deja vu on her face and then
on the next page as peter decides not to
tell her and walks out the door it says
hold on mj watching peter go with the
lingering sense of recognition and then
we move on to the final sequence as
peter swings in with his new suit on
page 181 the script describes it as a
blue and red suit new for him but
reminiscent of the suits he's seen
before meaning that peter was directly
inspired by those hand-stitched brighter
colors of the suits of his predecessors
a major lesson that he learned rather
than having a billionaire engineer to
sign all your tech for you an important
rite of passage is to stitch your own
suit and then the awesome final words of
the script he swings with a newfound
sense of freedom liberated from having
to juggle two lives peter parker is no
more but spider-man lives on fade out ah
yes now while it is easy to walk out of
this film feeling a bit down about the
stranger peter now is in his world cut
off from everyone he loves hearing it
this way reminds me of how his peter
parker identity always weighed him down
the opening shots at spider-man
homecoming showed us a kid itching to
escape from his life as a bullied high
school student so that he could come
alive finally at the end of the day as a
masked friendly neighborhood spider-man
and this ending finally gives him that
freedom you can support new rockstars by
checking out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at avos follow new
rockstars subscribe to the rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
foreign